remember when i joked about doing an ad
read in the middle of a tick tock
that's like a huge ass trend on tech
talk now
it was during the the one
because when we were when i was bagging
on or i was making fun of the demilios
and i was like what is a fun you know
and i was like you were like what's a
funny ad read that charlie could do in
the middle or yeah charlie could do in
the middle of her tech talk and i was
like blue chew
people are doing that [ __ ] now like
they're doing tick tocks and they're
doing ad reads in the middle like fake
ad reads what oh fake they're fake
yeah oh okay okay i mean it's only a
matter of time before they're real i
know but then but dude that was that was
one of the ones that
one of the remember that meme that you
showed me of of the video game
clips yeah where they like edit in the
pictures yeah and then in that one it
was just an entire ad for a hyundai oh
yeah yeah
yeah
like the whole thing it was like three
minutes long yeah it was like an entire
ad yeah
he's about to kill someone that's a
three-minute ad for the truck and then
right after the end of the [ __ ]
commercial he kills the guy yeah
yeah like
[ __ ] sick kill i don't know what's up
with the [ __ ]
sick truck what's up with that hyundai
ad
[Music]
yeah what's no i think they're like sick
drug man what's up with that ad at the
beginning for like that shooting game oh
yeah it was good
that's good
you